うん
そう、理工だからね、乗った途端に
乗ったのかどうか分かるんですよね
そうなんですよね
まあ、またやっぱり、ごまん乗らなくて
まあ、ぜひね
乗りたいよね
これはね、馬の雑誌なんですけど
これ僕のあの
よく馬科学会ってとこで
公演をやってくれって言ってるんだけど
その時の公演で
これフランスのドートンヌの会長と
お話しした時の写真とか
これね、僕の若い時代です
生涯に富んでいる
まだ20代の
こういうのが
前の学生とか
商売を飛んでました
今はもう絵の方
中心ですけど
これはね、フランス遊び行った時の
フランスの牧場の
馬の雑誌の場合
うん
馬はね、外国行っても馬ばっかりはしてるんですけど
競馬場でこういう展示会であったりとか
これは僕が教えている馬術の授業の写真から
馬に乗ってる人がいて
はい、ほらいいですね
このぐらい学生がいて
毎週教えてもらう
うん
きれいよね
色はね、できるだけ発色のいい色を使う
うん
あまり混ぜない
実はこういうのが
ステンシルっていう方なんです
馬の型を作って
はい
色を乗せて
そうするときれいな馬の形だけが
彫り回るので
わー
馬のシルエットってすごいきれい
きれいですよね
はい
あの真ん中もそう、それもきれいです
馬は一世こう、グッと回ると
足をね、こうやってくるって
めっちゃかっこいいんですよね
うんうんうん
なかなかこう足が上がってこなくて
自分が
馬がこう
エネルギーがないで
こういう風には
上がってこないですけど
そうなったときはすごいきれいな形
うん
これすごいナイス